it's the whole thing is so trippy to me
and so excited
it's really it's really bananas
catherine hahn has a spellbound with her
role on wandavision
while she's no newcomer to the acting
scene her role as agatha harkness breaks
the mold of her previous work
a magical performance like that takes a
ton of work from makeup to wardrobe to
hand gestures
and brushing up on mcu's lore star of
the show
han really threw her all into bringing
agatha and agnes to life on screen
this is gonna be a gas
catherine han came to the set with her
own ideas about the makeup for the 80s
era of episode four
featuring bright pink lipstick and heavy
purple eyeliner that gave her a look
straight out of an old 80s aerobics
video similar to the look agnes rocks in
the episode
han did have a perm back in the day she
only got one though so
she ended up with straight hair on top
and fried perm hair on the bottom as it
grew out
luckily no one on set was required to
get perms switching between the wildly
different hairstyles of the decades
wasn't practical for filming
or healthy hair wandavision scenes were
filmed out of order and sometimes they
worked on more than one era in a single
day
the solution was providing wigs for each
decade from the 50s to the 80s
for all of the show's principal actors
there's no shortage of praise from the
team behind the costumes in one division
especially from catherine herself she
called costume designer mayas rubeo a
wizard as she marveled at her attention
to detail
the designer is such a genius and such
an artist every little thing was era
appropriate
even the undergarments wearing
everything from corseted dresses
to pants with naughty bedazzled on the
butt catherine rocked
every look she wore on the show her
favorite costume was her getup for the
50s
she recalled rubeo choosing each color
carefully according to what would pop
the most in the black and white footage
her only regret is that the audience
didn't get to see the colorful clothes
in all their glory
hopefully we'll get to see all those
sets and costumes in full color when the
making of wandavision comes out
the hand gestures for spell casting in
the mcu look so cool because they're
carefully choreographed
if preparing for the role of agatha
harkness was anything like benedict
cumberbatch's training to play doctor
strange
she probably worked with a hand
choreographer cumberbatch worked with
breakdancer jay funk
who designed each gesture and movement
for the sorcerer supreme's magic
it takes a lot of practice to get the
movements just right when han would
practice her hand gestures at home
much to her kids embarrassment it was as
if they had walked in on me just getting
out of the shower they literally were
like oh my god mom
like i was practicing my witch moves and
they were so embarrassed
she thinks they were impressed with the
final product with the special effects
your own teenagers are probably the
hardest critics to impress so
that practice paid off
jumping into the mcu with no prior
knowledge is a daunting task
like diving right into the deep end of a
pool that was exactly what catherine han
did when she accepted the role of agatha
harkness
despite providing the voice of dr olivia
octavia and into the spider-verse
she wasn't all that well-versed in the
lore of the live-action marvel movies
she had a lot of research to do not only
reading the comics to learn about agatha
but
familiarizing herself with the entirety
of the mcu
it was a little bit of a word salad
walking into this i i couldn't remember
who was who and what was what luckily
she had some help
her kids were able to help her make
sense of everything going on in the
marvel movies
with the success of wandavision and the
big reveal of agatha harkness
catherine hahn has absolutely stolen the
show in what has been termed the hana
songs
she's getting some well-deserved
recognition gifts and memes of agnes and
agatha have been all over social media
bringing catherine han into the
spotlight it's a testament to how her
performance has really charmed us
but this isn't the first time we've seen
han stealing the spotlight
really she's been putting on amazing
performances and stealing
any scene she's in for years oh your
life is gross
my life is amazing now her status as a
household name has taken off with the
success of wandavision
we all know that the best villains have
their own song after being released as
part of the one division soundtrack on
february 23rd
agatha all along rocketed up to the
number one spot on itunes with more than
two million streams and counting on
spotify
han's reaction she was baffled catherine
doesn't use social media so the news
came as a huge shock to her
like i don't have social media so the
whole thing was like filtered down
through like all this i was like
are you kidding me she expressed her
amazement at the massive fan response in
an interview with seth meyers
laughing in disbelief and calling the
song success bonkers
i was told i was also like
what the success of agatha all along is
hardly surprising to us though
considering it was brought to us by the
same songwriting duo that worked on
frozen two
that explains why none of us have been
able to get that jaunty little jingle
out of our heads
marvel is infamous for its tight-lipped
policies when it comes to keeping plot
details from their actors
but not for katherine han it seems when
she met with marvel executives they laid
out the entire plot of wandavision for
her
since it was critical that she
understood her role as agatha harkness
even while playing agnes i am
really turning out to be a fantastic
secret keeper despite marvel's penchant
for secrecy
she ended up spilling a few details to
her kids but given that most of her work
is too mature for them to enjoy
she probably couldn't help herself she
was excited to be able to share one of
her acting roles with them and watching
one division together became a friday
night ritual for her family
just be able to like watch it with them
has been such a sweet
friday night ritual that i'm gonna be
i'm already nostalgic
the casting process for marvel studios
is long and involved
so long that tom holland initially
thought he hadn't landed the role of
spider-man
at all after going months without
hearing back from marvel's executives
for katherine han though the process was
unusually fast
it seems like her character isn't the
only one breaking all the rules
han happened to visit for an unrelated
general meeting with luis desposito
around the same time the writers sat
down to think about who they wanted to
play agnes
immediately someone brought up catherine
general meetings are already pretty rare
for marvel studios
the fact that it coincided so closely
with the casting meeting for agatha is
timing
so perfect it almost seems like fate we
don't usually cast like that
it's not usually like who came in the
other day let's cast them
it's almost never like that as a matter
of fact but it's usually never as
perfect as this
said kevin feige
what was it that drew catherine han to
the role if she wasn't already a big fan
of the mcu
according to her it was an acting
challenge she couldn't resist
she loved the idea of playing a single
character through the lens of different
decades
evolving to fit each era while remaining
true to the character's core
there was also a huge appeal in playing
a powerful witch hiding in plain sight
i couldn't have dreamt a cooler part
honestly i was thrilled she gushed
watching her in the role it's easy to
see that she's having tons of fun with
it
don't shoot i'm just a messenger
with a resume like hers it's no wonder
catherine hahn absolutely nails it as
the hilariously nosy neighbor agnes
as well as the manipulative magic user
agatha she's finally being recognized as
an underappreciated talent and despite
rarely landing a starring role she's
been stealing the show as supporting
cast and side characters for years
she has a strong comedic background from
her roles in shows and movies like parks
and rec
i love dick and bad moms but she's fully
capable of drama too
she shows off her acting chops and i
know this much is true
and private life not to mention into the
spider-verse where she proved that
she has what it takes to pull off an
iconic chaotic marvel villain
my enemies call me doc ock she's a
skilled performer that always
brings charisma to the table and it's
about time she got some recognition for
it
as if we didn't already have enough
reasons to love catherine hahn
her family has been fostering kittens
from a local animal shelter during the
pandemic
it was her daughter's idea but she's
loved the experience of offering their
home to animals in need during a time of
crisis